braucht man geld und luxus um glücklich
zu sein nicht unbedingt aber es hilft
dabei sich zu belohnen sagt luxusuhren
youtuber und verkäufer marc gebauer ich
kaufe mir so etwas zum beispiel um
solche meilensteine in meinem leben
festzuhalten zu sagen darauf arbeit hin
und das ist etwas was ich mir leiste
falls sich diese eine sache geschafft
habe aber diese essenz von glücklichsein
bestimmt durch diesen materialismus das
wird nur in mehr konsumenten deutlicher
wird da schon der aktivist und autor des
buches glücklich ohne geld ralf hellmer
heute hatte einen online shop in dem er
gerettete lebensmittel verkauft ich bin
raphael aus berlin und bin davon
überzeugt dass das glück von innen kommt
das heißt dass wir uns mit dem was wir
haben glücklich schätzen können und
dankbar dafür sein können und sollten
und dass familie freunde beziehungen das
allerwichtigste sind um glücklich zu
sein
ich habe gehört wir ziehen heute ein
bisschen um die häuser also ich bin
bestimmt heute sehr glücklich mit als
ich freue mich auch drauf mal gucken sie
mal los wir schicken die beiden einen
tag lang auf einen roadtrip beide haben
keine ahnung was heute passiert nur dass
wir ihnen am ende die frage stellen
trefft ihr euch in der mitte gibt es
eine grauzone
ich habe mich 2020 selbstständig gemacht
wir verkaufen ausschließlich im internet
foren und papa also die diesen markenmix
den wir haben ist schon relativ
einzigartig was ist der markt also ist
alles nur auf das beste ausgerichtet was
man kaufen kann es gibt keine abkürzung
und beim papa es auch so dass wir uns da
nur die besten halt aussuchen und
versuchen qualitativ immer halt das
hochwertigste zu nehmen aber etwas was
genau also welchen bereichen es dann
genau tätig also das was machst du hier
hätten lebensmittel die entlang der
wertschöpfungskette übrig geblieben sind
oder nicht mehr verkauft werden können
auf dem normalen leben angefangen hat
alles 2009 da habe ich ein youtube video
gesehen wie die leute aus einer
mülltonne lebensmittel raus container
konnten
ich kann das vorher nicht mal verfolgt
haften also die so bei den videos meist
jemand was back was messbar sondern habe
ich ja
mit der thematik wir sind näher befasst
und habe mich dann für geld streik
entschlossen okay das heißt kein geld
anzunehmen und kein geld auszugeben ich
habe quasi
abgelehnt da ja nicht benutzt streik
okay ich finde es cool man hat ja zwei
extreme beispiele duden das geldsystem
komplett
für eine gewisse zeit verneint hat und
der gegensatz ist natürlich dass jetzt
unser geschäftsmodell darauf abzielt
halt dinge zu verkaufen profite zu
realisieren dass man dadurch hat das
geschäft dann größer macht er wirkt auf
mich jetzt also wirst du dich selber ist
wirklich bezeichnen
unser erster stock bringt die beiden
nachbarn hier am brig institut und die
happy end in die quality wird unter
anderem genau unsere frage erforscht
kann geld glücklich machen also kann man
morgens aufwacht
armin falk leitet das break und sein
experiment kann uns der antwort auf
unsere frage einen ganzen schritt näher
bringen und das auch noch
wissenschaftlich belegen wir wurden
heute mit der frage konfrontiert
macht geld glücklich oder macht luxus
glücklich ja geld macht glücklich also
durchgängig ja ich kann es ein kleines
bisschen normal vielleicht qualifizieren
aber entgegen sozusagen dieser
landläufige meinung nach ja geld das
macht uns ja nicht glücklich stimmt ja
ab einem bestimmten einkommen
zusammen und ich habe verstanden dass
geld uns bis zu einem bestimmten ebene
glücklich macht dann gibt es noch einen
kleinen unterschied mehr weiß nicht ob
das 80 90.000 war in deutschland oder
irgendwo und dann gehts aber man sei da
aber das habe ich nie verstanden weil
zum beispiel wo ist die ganze
hunderttausend na ja die ist für jeden
ein bisschen unterschiedlich aber die
sagen wir mal so die effekte werden
schwächer die blaue okay aber der große
anstieg nur die große variationen sind
und das geld beruhigt ein fachgeschäft
ich glaube das ist nicht mehr sicher
dass man sich überlegt was bedeutet das
geld zu haben das hat er mal so was was
fast unangenehmes oder 100 ist so geld
geld kaufte sicherheit geld kaufte
gesundheit geld kaufte aufmerksamkeit
geld kaufte bildung geld kaufte zugänge
und geld kauft auch lebenserwartungen
wir haben auch in deutschland starken
gradienten abhängig von
sozioökonomischen status ist die
lebenserwartung nehme wenn ich mir geld
haben ja warum ist das so die wohnen in
den besseren wohnungen die sind weniger
umweltgiften und und lärm ausgesetzt die
haben die besseren jobs die weniger
gefährden dh zu sagen geld auf dem konto
ja habe ich da so ein aktienpaket von
damit das macht mich vielleicht nicht so
glücklich ja das kann sein aber das geld
ist ein potenzial mit dem ich was machen
kann und das war's dann leute im
entscheidenden in krisen zum beispiel
geld machen das hilft dann eben und das
verlängert zum beispiel das leben das
kann man ganz einfach zeigen gerade wenn
man wenig halt mehr geld tatsächlich
auch glücklich erwarte dass wir im
experiment zeigen ist ob ein solches
verhalten glücklicher macht oder nicht
und da konnte die probanden im prinzip
entscheiden ob sie menschenleben retten
wollen oder geld für sich bekommen und
in der kurzen frist können wir dann
zeigen dass
das menschenleben retten schon so mit
positiven stimmungen und zum kleinen
boost denn der herr minister für bundes
defekt ist aber sehr klein vier wochen
später drehte sich das bild komplett um
leute die das leben gerettet habe wir
sind weniger glücklich als die die 100
euro bekommen haben und das liegt
zumindest nahe dass es nicht ganz so
einfach ist dass wir nur einfach uns
umdrehen müssen positionen und dann
sofort glücklich werden wenn das so wäre
dann würden wir auch in anderen welt
leben als das tatsächlich tun würde ich
sagen und das ist auf eine art ein
bisschen auch ein enttäuschender oder
trister befunden jetzt natürlich die
frage warum warum weil weil eben sie war
mit 100 euro glücklicher als mit den
menschen leben ja
immer traurig ja das ist es traurig wenn
ich jetzt einmal so jemanden eine spende
entscheidung gebe und dass wir so ein
glücksempfinden dann wird das auch immer
man gerade war jetzt immer das findet
nicht statt also scheinbar reicht es
nicht so eine erfahrung einer oder
kurzfristig zum einen weil versteht es
trotzdem nicht weil es gerade erzählt
man erzählt es dann weiter wenn ich
jetzt sage ich habe menschenleben
gerettet tatsächlich da weiterhin fühle
mich dadurch besser als 100 euro oder da
steht es ist ja auch dass das niemand
macht ich habe ja nur das war eine
statistische mittelwerte und das ist
auch ein ganz neues vorkommen richter
sind da sind total wichtiges motiv warum
es überhaupt prosoziale handlungen noch
gibt und wenn ich das gut weiter
erzählen kann oder wenn ich dann
beobachtet werde dann wäre auch das hat
noch viele viele exponenten gezeigt
steigt auch die wahrscheinlichkeit das
ist richtig das ist sozusagen ein faktor
der darin die andere richtung geben ich
bin super erstaunt dass die leute eher
das geld das das also wirklich
glücklicher macht als es daher noch
nicht also ich glaub dir schon aber ich
kannte ich hatte ein anderes menschen
bilden muss ich sagen tut mir leid
dann vielen dank ja es ist wahr als
alles gute bis bald
ich bin krank er ließ den sommer ja
gleichfalls denkst du dass die
menschheit verloren es nach den
erkenntnissen also ich hab ja irgendwie
zum einen wissen so ein gefühl das
eigentlich traurig aber mich ansporn
dass man irgendwie noch mehr an
ich sehe das gute in der menschheit
neben menschen dass wir noch mehr tun
müssen um das noch mehr menschen lieber
ein leben leben retten als 100 euro auf
dem bankkonto zu haben
schreibt mich an noch mehr zu tun ich
habe es irgendwie so gar nicht an sagt
als er das gesagt hat dass er es
gemessen hat
[Musik]
ich glaube ich auch immer noch nicht gab
aber aber mit dem mit dem geld muss man
sagen das war's auch schon so ne also
wir haben sehr viele sachen die wir hier
diskutiert haben hat er ja auch
irgendwie bestätigt also dass man geld
nutzen kann damit es
so mit seinem besser geht es ja auch
feststellen können auf jeden fall auch
mit dem geld das das dann wenn ich schon
mal 100.000 euro verdiene dann bin ich
damit schon ganz glücklich wenn ich
jetzt über 200.000 euro für die nicht
doppelt glücklich sagen im zweifel
nicht mehr sehr viel mehr glück erhält
also das ist wie mit ja wenn ich zwei
autos habe
kannst du wieso nicht beides
gleichzeitig nutzen also steigt dann
einfach nicht mehr sehr und ich glaube
dass es ein
erkenntnis bestimmten stimmt bei uns zum
beispiel gibt es auch kunden
die
sich sagen die kaufmann nur
3000 euro
und sagen dann ja ok habe ich gekauft
was kann ich das nicht kaufen sondern
das ist so wie derjenige der sie fast
wie eine droge dass man sagt ich musste
mehr
das ist mehr oder nur noch teure klar
niemand möchte dann schon zurück machen
in den bonner rheinauen gar nicht weit
vom blick institute treffen wir auf marx
freut es mag hat die frage ob man geld
für das eigene glück braucht für sich
ganz anders beantwortet und daraus seine
ganz persönlichen schlüsse gezogen
[Musik]
was machst du denn so ja ich bin vor
neun jahren in den wald gezogen nach
einer schweren lebenskrise um der frage
nachzugehen
ja wie viel ich brauche wie viel geld
ich brauche und wie ich mein glück ein
bisschen steigern kann meine
lebensqualität und hast du dein glück im
wald gefunden ja auf jeden fall also mir
geht es deutlich besser als früher und
ich musste natürlich viele sachen ändern
aber das erzähle euch dann gleich
[Musik]
die einem 70 glücklich wenn er mit
menschen zusammen ist der andere ist
glücklich wenn er auf dem schnellen
motorrad sitzt der andere ist glücklich
wenn dann feinen anzug
oder wiederum eine reise möglich werde
auf golfplatz steht früher und bei dir
also wann hast du oder warum hast du
diese entscheidung jetzt so getroffen ja
das kam aus diversen problemen heraus
also ich hab mobbing erlebt ich war
unzufrieden mit dem mit meinem job als
golflehrer damals
ja ich war golflehrer bundesliga gold
für die
familie also von daher
bin ich so also ich sehe mich so als die
könnte selbst aus euch bei ja ich kenne
das eine ich kenne das andere und ich
bin da nicht total abgeneigt ja und was
war der impuls oder ja unzufriedenheit
im job ich wusste nicht mehr wie ich
meine miete bezahlen soll ich wollte
mehr in der natur seien ja auch eben dem
thema minimalismus nachgehen
rausfinden wie wenig eigentlich brauche
ich hab dann zum beispiel 2015 sieben
halb 1000 euro umsatz gemacht und habe
von viereinhalb tausend euro gelebt in
dem ganzen jahr wenn mir das früher
einer erzählt hätte als ich noch
golflehrer war und so in dieser in
dieser geld spirale steckte der ich
gesagt du bist verrückt das gibt es
nicht
mir ist total wagen können wir irgendwo
für die zukunft was hast du noch für
träume was habe ich nur für träume also
ich versuche eigentlich
ja mehr mehr im heute zu leben
[Musik]
ich habe eigentlich nicht so viel also
ich bin recht zufrieden heute somit
allen clubs sagen kann
klasse ich war
wenig geerdet was ich heute
was ich heute bin und ich habe mir über
sachen gedanken gemacht und ängste
gehabt die völlig überflüssig waren
und ich glaube da geht es vielen leuten
heute auch so mit sicherheit ja also für
dich geht es jetzt zurück wahrscheinlich
ja dann vielen dank für eine zeit da
fand ich auch
sagt man jetzt hast du hast du
irgendwelche sachen so in ihm gesehen
die auch mit dir gleich sind weil du
warst ja auch lange in der natur
unterwegs
ja ich war eigentlich nicht so viel ich
bin gereist in der natur und dann habe
ich aber in einer stadt gewohnt ich bin
jetzt quasi ein workaholic und ich war
einmal ein geldstreit auch ein
workaholic weil ich immer die mission
habe den ort stellen der welt schaffen
in der alle menschen genügend zu essen
haben das treibt mich an und da ist für
mich diese ich habe jetzt freizeit und
jetzt mal das ist für mich mein herz
brennt so für die er sich würdig
unglücklich machen wenn es nicht tust ja
also das merkt man auch im gespräch
jetzt was mit ihm gesprochen haben für
sich selber hat er eine glückliche welt
jetzt übergeordnet ist es so natürlich
wenn er jetzt kurse anbietet wird er
schon auch was zu sagen wir mal zu der
gesellschaft dazu beitragen und so auf
jeden fall aber wenn jetzt alle leute
sich aus der gesellschaft heraus ziehen
wird könnte es auch schon eventuell zu
problemen führen die letzte station
unseres roadtrips liegt genau in der
mitte der ersten beiden stationen
treffen sich marx und raphael auch in
der mitte in der grauzone ich denke
nicht dass man geld zwangsweise braucht
um glücklich zu sein oder was sein
ich glaube auch nicht vor allem wenn man
es nicht will ich glaube mein geld will
und man hat keines dann ist man nicht
glücklich aber der professor oder der
doktor mit dem wir gesprochen das buch
geschrieben hat hat da schon recht dass
es gewisse vorteile bietet und das was
du im auto gesagt hast dass man es als
werkzeug nutzt ich denke das ist das was
man mitnehmen kann und vor allem geht es
darum was mache ich mit dem geld das ist
eine verantwortung die ich habe und wie
kann ich die möglichst so einsetzen für
die anderen lebewesen auf der erde dass
du auch was davon haben also muss man
sagen wir sind uns doch dann irgendwie
relativ ähnlich also war ein aufregender
tag wir haben neue beziehungen
geschlossen und es hat mich sehr viel
weitergebracht muss sein
wie seht ihr das braucht es geld oder
luxus um glücklich zu sein schreibt es
uns in die kommentare
und wenn ihr wissen wollt ob wir doch
nicht alle verzichten sollten um den
planeten zu retten dann schaut euch
jetzt die ganze doku in der zdf
mediathek